all right selena
selena where'd you grow up where are you
from originally um i'm from riverside
california
but i was born in san bernardino
and then until i was 15
going on 16 until i was 18 i was in utah
i lived in utah for therapy about your
family you had both your parents when
you were a kid
um i'm adopted i've been in
well i was in when i was born they put
me in the system because my mom was
doing meth
so like they already knew like when i
was born i'm going straight there
when i was around one and a half going
on two
my mom adopted me and she raised me
so you were raised by adopted parents
yeah um
my mom was running like a foster care
system and she only like was able to
keep four of us
and she already had four of her own so
it was like eight of us together
how would you describe your childhood um
it was like it wasn't bad but
there was like skeletons in the closet
things that i was going through but i
wasn't allowed to go to school and tell
or when the social worker would come i
wasn't allowed to say
anything what happens in this house
stays in this house and what kind of
business
a lot of like sexual abuse and
physical abuse um
you know i had nieces and nephews and i
didn't want to see them or
see them being taken away from my sister
so i didn't say anything i wouldn't say
anything
[Music]
it was pretty much something that was
happening behind closed doors
as well and she was it was i came to her
already touched so you know my birth
grandparents had me
for a little bit and they were molesting
me
and so she had to deal with that with me
and
my brother being touched when he was
little
well your adopted mom didn't step in and
protect you or
um she did well she felt like sending me
to therapy and like
mental hospitals and getting me on
antidepressants and stuff was what was
helping me
and she sent me to utah and i spent two
well i spent my 16th birthday in utah
and um in a wilderness ascent program i
was out there for five months and then
they
transferred me to a boarding school and
i spent the rest of my birthdays there
and
i don't know i kind of like got mad and
i felt abandoned
like almost forgotten about because they
didn't send me anything they wouldn't
send me stuff that i would need for
boarding school and i
pretty much got hand-me-downs and when i
was 18 i just signed myself out
she was upset with me so she didn't let
me stay with her
that's how i came to la because
she was upset with the fact that i
didn't finish the program
when i was 18 i just jumped and just
they got me a flight to long beach i
came along we
came straight out here and she
said you know you've been gone this long
we don't know who you are anymore it's
gonna take a lot for us to learn you and
you know we're not ready for us to they
pretty much like wasn't
ready to deal with the new me and
yeah so you came to l.a and is that when
your
work as a prostitute started um
i had a boyfriend that i was talking to
when i got out that i was
talking to before i went in and he
pretty much took me under his wing
for like a couple months i got into it
with him and we were staying at compton
and um you know we were towards long
beach boulevard
and at the time i didn't know what long
beach boulevard or
what any blade was i didn't know what
this game was about
and you know
me and him got into it and i was in my
pajamas
but my pajamas is more like lingerie
type he threw me out the house
i was like [ __ ] if you think you you
think you're gonna come in here
and just what do you uh pretty much go
out there and go figure it out
you know when you're ready to get your
[ __ ] together you can come back type
[ __ ]
i was crying i was calling my mom and
she told me that i couldn't come back to
go to a homeless shelter
because she couldn't get me and that you
know my sister still didn't forgive me
for what was happening before i got sent
away
and this this dude with like chains
pulled up on me
he was like what's up little mama why
are you crying i was like you're too
pretty to cry he was like why are you
crying
and i just said look can i please use
your phone he was like
um what happened to yours and i have one
but it was turned off he had turned my
phone off it was like an obama type
phone
and um he cut the line off and i
got in the car with him and he just like
was like do you drink
no do you smoke no
and he said okay well where you from and
i pretty much told him like what
happened
and i cut it down to bits and pieces not
really like
going into it and i guess it kind of
gave him the idea like okay she's out
here alone nobody knows her nobody gives
a [ __ ] about her
and we talked a little bit and he said
well you know i get money
and i said well yeah he says so
what do you plan on doing with yourself
like you know you were living with your
boyfriend
i know that's not doing nothing i know
he got kids and
he pretty much like bashed him for
being square like and bashed me for
laying up and being given my time or
my worth to the square that just threw
me
out to the wolves pretty much
he said you know you can't just get in
anybody's car
but in the midst of that he was hitting
powder like he was hitting powder
and um i don't know something in him
snapped because i asked him to drop me
back off
he was like you just got my car
you ain't got no money or nothing like
he said you can't make it up
he said you can't make it up by giving
me some sex or something
and i was like what are you talking
about he was like some heads something
like you ain't got no dough he was like
you gotta give me something
and i try to like i try to like play it
off and try to just jump out the car
and he knew i was trying to get out the
car because as soon as i
opened the door he pulled my hair back
socked me in the face he was like okay
i'm gonna show you what
i'm gonna show you a plan what pimpin
does i was like pimping
and so he was uh he had me by my hair
threw my phone out the window
and he pretty much was playing
sugar-free in the background
and i didn't know i i didn't know at the
time who sugar free was but he was
spending all this game
and he was telling me i'm going to bring
you to this blade [ __ ]
you're not allowed to talk to no black
dudes no black he said unless they're
trying to offer money you can't date
them
he pretty much told me what staying in
pocket was
and you know
from there to him bringing me to pomona
that was the first blade i got down on
and actually started working and caught
my first date
and survival mode i'd even
think to i'd even pay him pretty much
my first date i used that money to ask
someone else to bring me back
to la and i got to la
and um when the dude that helped me
was bringing me back to la he let me use
his phone
and i was using the phone and i was
talking to someone that had just got out
of jail
i told him everything that the dude told
me in the car
and i said look i need money i just need
to get somewhere
like far away from here back home i
don't care
i wasn't gonna do it and i don't know
the money started coming in quicker that
night when i got down on fig
and i liked i liked it i liked the
adrenaline
i liked that i didn't like how it
happened
but the dude that was talking to me he
said you can't be out here
weak he said you know that you pray out
here you you gotta you gotta
like you gotta put your chin up type
[ __ ]
he was telling me like you know do
do all that [ __ ] when you get the money
and you're able to go sit behind a
in a nice tub or go get yourself a bath
water and just sit in there and cry and
feel the way you want to feel right now
he said but right now life is going on
life is moving past you while you're
sitting here crying about what this
[ __ ] did he said if he out here doing
that
to girls he's going to be out here again
and that he was going to be touched and
found
and i don't know he tried to make me he
made me feel like
i wasn't gonna be scared working out
there like he wasn't gonna find me again
and um i don't know
just started doing it for a while
and i was going traveling from
different cities and learning the
different tracks and
that's how i was just getting my money
but the money you would get you would
give to him
yeah i wouldn't tuck
i wouldn't save anything um
at first i told him that my mom was sick
and that it was for that
and it kind of like
i kind of lost focus and why i was out
there because the money was so good
i started to get greedy and i was
you know letting him get me this
and spend it on you know expensive rooms
that we were trapping in and
was your mom actually sick yeah she was
sick at the time
but she kept making me feel like she
didn't need my money she didn't want it
type [ __ ] like she'd
now keep it um whenever i would try and
offer it to her
like well at first when i got out of
treatment it was my
mom that was kind of upset that i signed
myself out
but when i had tried to get back in
touch with my mom she was in a
a group home like an uh for like you
know sick older people
and my sisters would refuse to tell me
where my mom was so
i wasn't really out there you know
knowing where she was i just knew i was
going to get the money
and i was going to either take off with
how much he was saving
or i was just gonna start tucking
because i was like okay now i'm starting
to get sidetracked like
i'm starting to just do this and like
he's you you're getting too fly now
like you're getting too much out of this
now and i need to get back in touch with
my mom
because when i was in a relationship
with the dude in compton
i was still in touch with her and i was
talking to her
and then that was the last time i called
her before i found out that
my sisters were keeping her somewhere in
like a seniority home because they
didn't want to take care of her
well that's how i felt and that's how my
mom felt
and i don't know
it got too fun and i got too sidetracked
and i started to see like
i started to put myself in my mom's
shoes and was like well
how would i feel doable so i
left and he made me feel that there was
a game god
and so like when you leave like a bunch
of bad [ __ ] happens to you
and i felt like that because i was
homeless i didn't have anywhere to go
i was sleeping in my friend's car i
didn't know how to get the money and
get down without feeling like somebody
was going to do something because i
didn't know anyone to call and ask to
come help me
um i was robbed my first time for
carrying too much money on me
so i didn't have a like
place to pretty much put my money in and
feel like okay i know what i'm gonna do
with it
i know where i'm going to put it
i had was already talking to someone
else
and that's when i met the dude that kind
of
was pimping me here and there but was
like my boyfriend type
well that's what they call a boyfriend
pimp and uh
he helped me find my mom and
i found my mom around christmas time
like last year on christmas time last
year
i was popping up i just went to pop-up
to go see her
no no she looked like she was like
dying and i was sad and something
snapped at me
and i told him look my mom said that
she's gonna help us out with getting in
a car so i could come out here and help
her
now the goal this is why i feel like he
was starting to
keep me behind closed doors and not
wanting me out there
because my mom kept saying that she
didn't have enough money to pay for a
nurse to come take care of her
but then she wanted me to come take care
of her and i said well mom would you let
me come back home
if i'm able if i take care of you i stay
home with you every day and i you know
change your diaper and i read you books
and you know i'm here with you
and she said yeah but you know you got
to get along with the rest of the family
because you know our family you can't
just come in and just
think that everything's gonna bounce
back the way it was
and it was understandable i had a lot of
bridges
a lot of bridges that i burnt with them
and i had to make up for it and i wasn't
ready
because i felt now i was sleeping around
with too many men i was giving myself
away
they were going to be even more
disgusted with me so
i kept saying okay mom well let me get
the money and
let me at least get a car first and she
kept saying wellina
do you have a bank account and do you
have this and i can give you money you
know you
you have a check coming in and i said a
check coming in like what do you mean
um she said i want to give it to you she
said but
you're going to give it to you know she
already knew
i was going to give it to the person i
was with and
she said it was like a couple months
that it was coming in and so during
those months
i'm telling him look i'm going to have
this much he said okay well until
that much comes in i need you to trap
hard i need you to go all
in i need you to get the money get the
money
and in this and in the midst of this i
said okay if i go out there
you think you can take me to go get
certain stuff for my mom and i go visit
her and
i was visiting my mom and you know i
started getting back
into a relationship with her and it was
just me and my mom because she was in
the seniority home
that was my main focus money get it get
on my
get whatever my mom wants and just take
me to go see her
he started using that to like his
advantage until she gave me the check
and oh when the check came
like that was like when her eyes started
to turn like a like
kind of like grayish color and her hair
was you know
thinner um
she already knew that i was being abused
and stuff because there were certain
times i would call her
and like tell her look can you just
please let me come back home please
please let me come back home she always
felt like it was up to my sisters and my
brothers if
i was able to come home and so
my folks seen that and it kind of made
him mad
he was like why can't you have a
relationship with him and it kind of
like made him
hate my family even though he wasn't in
my family
um and he said like your mom doesn't do
anything to help you or defend you like
why should you have to give her anything
out of that check i've been taking care
of you this whole time
i'm the one that was taking you to go
see her for what he will
and i've got mad like i don't owe you
anything like
i'm making money and now that this money
coming in and it's around like april may
um it sounds like he's brainwashing you
yeah he
he was using the guilt of
mean like telling him i want to go see
my mom he would make me feel like i'm
asking him
too much because you know it's all the
way riverside and then traffic during
the day like
he just made me feel like walking on
eggshells all the time
like a ticking bomb but
i was too scared to go anywhere else
because
you know he wasn't keeping me out at
night like he wouldn't make him go out
at night like other most pimps would
um he kind of like made
introduced me to his mom and like we
were living with her for a little bit
um and this is when my mom was
like lost touch with me and i was losing
phones and
i was getting phones and i was losing
phones because there was dates that i
would catch that they either tried to
kidnap me or rob me and they've had to
take my phone or i've had to like run
and i've dropped it like either way
like my mom was losing she was getting
numbers from me and like it was not the
same number and she would say i called
that number i texted it
and you know i would worry about you and
why do you keep changing your phones
lena like you just need to stick to one
number
didn't take him until that 17 000 check
he started getting money
um for him to give me an iphone
[Music]
and you know i started
getting different money
and i my mom died on me
she passed away like august 9th and my
birthday is august 14th
she got coded on the 7th of august and i
felt like my sisters and them were
playing with me because
they said oh they brought mommy back to
life like like hey she's going to be
okay
she's just under like um
[Music]
a breathing machine they said that she's
on a breathing machine and there's a
certain medicine that's what's keeping
her alive
and i asked if i could see that if i
could see her and they said no
you can't see your coronavirus you know
we got to put the plug and i said you
don't have to pull the plug like there's
a decision like
you know i know it is because my little
sister was always telling me the truth
behind things because they would leave
me in the clue like they would leave me
in the blue like guessing
and my little sister would hit me up and
she said elena you know mommy's going to
call around 10 o'clock
on google duo facetime she said facetime
me
um daddy wants him to pull the plug
and you know i'm asking him like like
can you take me to riverside please like
my mom's in icu
like i need to go say goodbye to her and
he was like man
he was like uh man i you know i don't
give a i don't know why all of a sudden
you're trying to ask me to go now
knowing there's traffic
then what you say goodbye you go make me
feel bad because we don't get out there
in enough time [ __ ] or what
what i said no just take me out there so
i at least know that i made it out there
like
and i was able i tried and so
in the um mystery that i'm smoking and
i'm just getting prepared for it because
i'm not it doesn't feel real
it doesn't feel real you know that car
ride i had to say goodbye
there's a certain point he was
disrespecting me he was being rude
he was like pass me that pass me that
torch uh
pass me the scissors to cut the blunt
you know i'm on the phone
and like i'm muting it and i'm looking
at him i'm like
wanting to cry like don't you see my mom
like sick on the phone and like i'm
showing my sick mom
like on the phone and he was like
he was like man get that get the [ __ ]
out of my face with that all that [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] about all that
he was like man uh he said you gonna
piss me off cause then he was like you
know what's up he said
you're the family's on the phone i'm not
gonna say what's up
and that we hit a certain traffic on the
freeway where it kind of slowed down
and you know everybody in my family is
saying goodbye
so it's like oh my sister it's about to
be me it's about to be my turn
i hopped up i hopped out the car and i
started running
and i just get away from traffic and i
you know
say good my goodbye to my mom
started apologizing to her and he
tricked me and went behind my back and
that's why
my mom stopped talking to me about the
money because he had sent her a stack of
money and was like we won't be needing
you
and um he said he said
who is stack of money he said my mom he
texted her a picture
and was like she won't be needing you
anymore you know like you guys abandoned
her and left her now i got to deal with
her
like he's under a picture of money yeah
like now i gotta bring her and build her
back up
from what you and her disgusting ass
birth parents did
like you guys damaged her and now i got
it pretty much
he made he made it sound like there was
horrible people
and i don't know it kind of like broke
something in me but
i was scared to cry i wasn't allowed to
cry around him like that
um so
with that money we went to go to vegas
and he gets this whole penthouse
in vegas for my birthday and his
birthday because his birthday's a couple
days after and
you know he was like
you think your mom would want you going
outside and
you think your mom would be here like
wanting you to be sad type [ __ ] like i
brought you i got all this stuff
and with people for your birthday like
you got to be grateful
and i don't know
that from august to
november well going toward into december
of last year
i started working again but my best
friend died on me
and he was getting his money but i was
getting my own money so it was pretty
much
like i won't i don't need you but my mom
you know my mom's gonna look out for you
type [ __ ] like you could stay around you
could be around but like i won't i don't
need your money
like keep it and i was like now all of a
sudden you're gonna let me keep my money
and all of a sudden that i was doing it
for something and i feel like now it's
just i'm stuck with you
like i felt stuck and my best friend
came to visit me before my mom's funeral
and she told me like
you know i see you doing much more and
she was like i look up to you selena
she was like you're really my best
friend and i was like thank you athena
and she was like no it's okay to cry and
i said i don't want to cry though and
she said but it's okay too
she said um i'm not gonna hurt you i'm
not gonna hit you i'm not gonna make you
feel bad
and i don't know it's just so genuine
like because athena was always around me
and my mom
when we were younger i met her we've
been since the sandbox we were together
since the starbucks
and i'm in vegas again
he takes me to go to vegas but he goes
to vegas because he has something to
pick up that he left out there from the
last trip
and um he wanted to take me and i asked
him like no
i don't want to go you know because i
was still dealing with after my mom's
funeral and knowing that my family
didn't put me in the obituary they
didn't let me come and
bury her casket like they didn't tell me
where her burial was until the morning
of and
like they did they did stuff out of
pettiness like
out of spite but it was never like
behind me they didn't know that it was
his fault
and um yeah that's something that i'm
still dealing with is one
just getting my family back
we're not like it'll never be back the
way it was
but an understanding
sorry
i'm good
so are you still working today
somewhat um but you have somebody you're
giving money to or
no i've been like
just spending it on rooms and like [ __ ]
that i would need to
go throughout the day but i'm not really
trying to make myself seem out there in
the streets because
you know there's certain people that are
mad at me or that are looking for me
and that wants me to do with me based on
times that i was down and they
they didn't like that i was either
mexican or you know they thought i was a
minor
yeah you look young but you're you're
actually 20 yeah 20 years old
is it hard to be a renegade a renegade
well
yeah because you know it's not like a
respectable thing in the game
you know renegades are
according to people in the game yeah
like you're you're a target
if you're a renegade your target like
your free check
they'll wait for you you know the way
for you to collect amounts so
they'll do something grimy or you know
you're just not respected because
you don't have a man that's bossed up
and
looking to invest in you and put you in
a position to win
and you know i feel like it sounds like
a lot of brainwashing to me
yeah i feel like i've wasted a lot of
time trying to let somebody put me in a
position to win
when the whole time i've just wanted
to get right with my mom
and you know i was i was able to say
goodbye to athena
when i was in vegas but on the way back
to la we had stopped to go to sleep and
i don't know sheriffs came and we had
stuff in the car that
got us in trouble and i went to jail but
her mom had texted me like did you hear
what happened
i said no she said athena's brain dead i
said brain day was brain dead
i look it up and she's typing and
i could tell like she's typing and then
she'll delete it type it delete it
and then it said she's in riverside
community hospital i see you
she overdosed and
like i don't know something to me like
snapped it
like she overdosed off a percocet that
she
crushed and sniffed one line out of and
i was thinking because
i was doing percocets at the time like
why wasn't it me
like why her what not me you know
like i fell out with my mom i'm out here
doing stupid [ __ ]
i'm out here settling for something that
i feel is my worth like materialistic
stuff that i was getting
from the person i was dealing with and
then
giving my money away so i felt like
i just pretty much was just trying to
find like where i belong my spot and i
would have to pay my worth or my worth i
have to lower it
for them to accept me or for me to be
accepted and
you know i was like why why her not me
she was getting her [ __ ] together she
was barely starting
and she said that i was able to come say
goodbye to her but
i went to jail i ended up going to jail
and i wasn't able to say goodbye to her
i was only able to go to her candlelight
visual
and i asked again he had to take me
i had to rely on him to take me in
i don't know he doesn't do death very
well he's never been
he doesn't go to funerals so he feels
like the way he deals with death is what
i'm supposed to do with death
and so i missed out on her funeral and i
only went to a candle visual but
oh no i was i feel like
something in me is being pulled out of
this
you know there's different levels to it
once you get into it they
you know there's different parts of this
game that you play and there's different
areas and states of this game that you
play and
you know they call it levels and
elevating but
when you've been uh through so much in a
little bit amount of time
it's like why would i even waste a month
or a couple weeks
trying to work with a pimp or invest in
a
uh pay a pimp for his time for his worth
gamers they say game is to be sold not
told
okay well what am i learning that's
gonna
you know what type of investments are
you teaching me that's gonna
get me to learn how to be in real estate
or learn how to
or what techniques are you teaching me
to put me in a position to write a book
or to actually do something that i want
to do before i entered this
it's like invest my money in like
it's like people and it's
sad but it's not sad because did you end
up getting any money out of the
relationships you've had no what'd you
get when you
when you parted ways what did you get
it's not like you leave and it's like a
retirement fund
it's like you come in with nothing you
leave with nothing and if you
choose to mess with that person and you
know be down for them in their crown
then then you know that's where all the
all the little materialistic [ __ ] and
you know you have a place to stay in the
mansion or
in the house that they have and you know
but pimps they always start off with a
girlfriend or someone that
they feel should be the rest of their
life with in the game because they
started it off with and
that's how [ __ ] were trying to
blame me with okay
you might be my bottom [ __ ] you want
this so you're going to be my top tier
million dollar [ __ ] you're going to
bring in
all this money and you're going to do a
will
and it sound good it looked good but
it's like what are you really getting
like it's a mentally
it's a mental thing you have to be
mentally okay to go out there it's the
energy you carry
and i don't know in the midst of that
i was being choked out one day and then
slapped up the next and then thrown in
the tub and beat in the tub
because he said that i would be like out
of pocket
[ __ ] if i was a [ __ ] because
when he started to keep me inside and i
felt like i wasn't
you know i don't have a job to go to but
i don't have school to go to
and he was going to make his own money
i would ask him like can i go get down
because
i felt like you know i wanted to get out
the house
but i don't have nowhere to go kick it
out i don't have a car to drive and go
to the beach and smoke
the blade is right there i just go get
some money can i go do something
and i don't know
i would want to ask him to put me down
because i didn't like being inside the
house all the time and i would take
e-pills
and i was heavy off the e-pills until it
started making me lose a lot of weight
and i don't know i started to feel like
a smoker
because you know they put crystal in
that they put like meth
in there to fill the rest of the pill up
and then when he started beating me and
like
putting like actual fractures and i
broke ribs and you know actual pain
outside like the skin and internal pain
that i felt after and he would say oh
would you need it for now
because my chest hurting and just
talking you know like you know
i had to go to hospital plenty of times
because he broke my ribs
i felt like he gave me a concussion one
time they um
[Music]
he started giving me perk 30s
um because when he was giving me a crumb
of it
i was throwing it up so he tried to like
make me sniff it and i don't know
it was taking away the pain and i was
dealing with my mom's death
then i did this on my arm and um
he got mad at me like [ __ ] you think
your mom
wants you to be like why would you want
to [ __ ] kill yourself
like now i'm left to do it because your
mom's not here no more
and you know and i promised your mom
that i would take care of you and
that's what he said and i don't know
that was kind of like my gateway to
where people call me like
a smoker [ __ ] or that's why a lot of
people out there don't respect me or
they say that they
call me a [ __ ] [ __ ] or a faggo and
they don't like me because
i'd be taking the perk 30s and wanting
to
get money but don't have no one to give
my money to
i can't just trust anybody now and
it's like i'm not a step in my life
where
if i go out go get the money what am i
going to invest the money into
or if i go out go get the money what if
they find and spot me out
there and
i don't know what i'm supposed to do
right now because i'm not trying to
go to different pimps and you know
they put me back down on figs square one
are they taking me to out of state or
out of city
and i don't have a support system and i
don't have somebody to call and send me
money or i don't have a cash app for
somebody to cash at me
or send me a greyhound ticket anywhere
or plane ticket
like you know it's like you feel stuck
or you feel like you have to run back to
the person that you were
giving your money and time to because
they
already knew what was going on with you
and they know how to take care of you or
at least they know how to like
shut you up and
[Music]
you know there's missed in pieces in the
back
that i've had to deal with in being the
game
that i would feel guilty for now
if i speak on it
because i don't know
that one would lead to like a different
you know everything leads to like a
different
topic story
why this happened why this happened and
right now
i'm at a point where i'm just ready to
heal and deal with the trauma
that i went through in the streets and
with the tricks
and then with what domestic violence i
went through with him
and with other things that were going on
with outside with
again tricks and then along with you
know losing my mom and best friend like
it's like every day life goes by so fast
when you're in this game
it's like your survival mode you don't
have time to just sit and think about
the person you just lost so just talking
about it it's like damn
i'm not ready to sit and actually deal
with that so
if i gotta go out there and
catch dates to make things you know
distract me or
keep me occupied and busy like i'm
i feel the need to do that
or if i stop like
taking these like perk 30s or
you know a lot of the fake ones are
going around now so it's pretty much
fentanyl you're pretty much sniffing
fentanyl it's the worst drug
second drug to heroin that you like the
worst drug you can get addicted to
so
it's hard even just getting off that
because it's like the pain that i deal
with physically
i don't like pain i don't like physical
pain um
and yeah but you're lucky you're 20
years old and you you have no kids
yeah no kids um
i've i want i want kids i want
yeah but you're you're young and you're
free to leave now you could get out of
this
line of work if you wanted to yeah
and do it without having to feel like
guilty
or feel like i'm being held back or that
i have to do it but i have to stop and
you know people say like you in it to
get out of it
and it's like exactly but if i'm in it
and i'm spinning
you know i think about it too like what
how much money would i
have now if i really stopped and
calculated
and estimated how much i handed over to
these
pimps i would like be
on like i would i wouldn't have to be
out here how much money do you think
you've made
for them um
i would make at least like
so stacked up now from two years ago
that'd be like at least 50 60 bands
60 000. to me that's a lot
that's to start off with something and
you know i feel like one door can be
open to many other doors and
if i was to save that money and invest
it
and you know either go back to school
and figure out what i need to do
because in boarding school when i turned
18 i signed myself out i never finished
school
never went and got a ged or finished
college or anything and
i just got a job a little square job at
the warehouse
with the boyfriend i was with and then
just the game
just coming out here on the blades
and yeah
do you feel like you have any friends in
your life anyone you can trust
i have one friend named peyton but she's
a square
like she does her own thing and i don't
really feel like putting the burden on
her
but there's times where she's gotten me
a room where
she's put food on my stomach and clothes
on my back because she seen that
i was stuck stranded somewhere or
beat up somewhere and left on the side
of the freeway and i was
calling her to come help me or come pick
me up
um she reaches out to me now
but i don't know i haven't really felt
the need to want friends or i feel like
i don't
i don't i don't have the
the strength or the energy right now to
you know be around someone and actually
be a normal person because there's so
much stuff that i want to get out
and get off my chest
do you feel like the years that you've
done this kind of work has kind of
broken you
it's hard for you to get out now it's
like you're
you feel like you're stuck
like a lot of the girls that are out
here like being out here
because the childhood that they were
raised in
i wasn't raised into this lifestyle
so it took a lot of me to get
comfortable in it and then
now it's taken a lot of me to get out of
it
in a way that i think about how i
thought about the game and how i
actually was looking at it like
respecting it or tried to respect
whatever it was that i was being told
and how to look at it
and then i just think about how my mom
raised me
and the spiritual
woman she was and how she would sing to
me you know certain gospel songs
and i had to like stop and
listen to it and think about it and i
just it's something
it's something like on a personal level
with him and with my
mom that i lost that i feel
like if i get out this i have to face
the fact that i really don't have a mom
anymore
it sounds to me as an outsider
that you're ripe for being picked up
again by another guy
and then you'll be back in the same
situation again
[Music]
and no
my family worries for me to where like
my sister even asked to put me on life
insurance
and you know a little sister
cries through me sometimes about how
she's scared that i'm
i'm just gonna be left in the back
streets raped
by naked and dead there's times where i
felt like that was gonna happen
that's why i started to get angry
because these pips aren't on these dates
with us
they don't get in the car with us when
you don't know if somebody's gonna
easily
inject you with some horse tranquilizer
and rape drug and they call it a date
rape drug and
except for it's not the it's not the
it's not the whole taking the trick
money is the trick
taking not just the money but taking
like a piece of you
they're nasty like some people that go
out there look for more than sex
they look for torture because they get
aroused out of torture
or they get aroused out of having that
power feeling that power of
a girl asking us stop stop let me go get
out
like get off me
people are sick and i got mad like
you're not and i'm back there risking
your life
you you guys nice cars you know like
what are we paying you for
what are we paying you for because the
little game that you tell us
that we need is the little game that
could
get us killed and left somewhere
where we don't want to be there's some
people that
got rich off this don't have to come
back to this
and there's some people that
like just being out here they feel like
that's where their
their spirit is type and that's where
their soul is like attached to their
pimp and attached to the game
and people actually really like believe
in a game god and
you know i believe in one god that's the
same god that i feel like i need to get
right with when i feel stuck
because you know i don't have a mom
and that's who was there for everything
like when i got out of treatment even
though
she wasn't able to come and visit me
physically she
just to hear her voice or just to hear
that that comfort of knowing that
she still loved me behind no matter what
i did because my family was
so they're so good at holding grudges
like they don't
know how to forgive or let stuff go like
they'll hold on to it
so it would be hard for me to go back
home and have to hear
and deal with the guilt and not hear my
mom's comfort
to the closure of that saying i forgive
you
you know you got to forgive yourself
type [ __ ]
do you feel like you've mourned your
mom's death
just talking about it now it's like
crying about it now is kind of like
making me feel it because the only time
i cried
about her death is when i seen her in a
casket
she looked like she was smiling like
peaceful
like i know she was suffering
and dealing with like thank you
dealing with a lot of physical pain and
i don't know she was worried about me
sitting in that bed a majority of the
times and
my little sister i heard from my little
sister because
um she just turned 18 in february
like she's like lina like mommy can't
even see me
have kids or have a family and like that
touched me too
because it's true
like right when i want to get my life
together and have
proof to someone that i did it
that was the person i wanted to prove to
was my mom
and now i feel like i don't have nothing
left to no one left to
to live for like to do something that's
gonna
show that i've actually did it
like i fought through it and i dealt
with the pain that not only came with
the trauma and the physical trauma
like either to my body i'll flinch if
someone reaches in for a hug
or like um
certain tricks would think that i'm
trying to either hurt them or set them
up because i'll have like pepper spray
under my leg and like a pocket knife
right here and
go look at me and like it's like you can
never be too careful
and i don't want to feel like that
anymore i don't want to feel like i
always have to look over my shoulder
or you know like i have to pray every
day
every day that i don't come out here and
i die and like
like i feel like god if
i do something like please just don't
let me die out here i want to make
things right before i get out
i don't know i just want to forgive
the people in the game that
not brought me in it because it's like i
feel like it's what's going to
build me but forgive
like what they started to imp like and
put in my head to make me feel
like i'm less than of a person
and because i'm not a hoe
i'm not good enough because i'm not
paying a pimp i'm not good enough
or i shouldn't be out there and i just
need to be slick my easily cut
do you feel like they've kind of changed
the way you think about yourself and see
yourself
that they've changed it or that they're
going i mean it sounds like you're very
you have a very negative self-image now
it seems like you've been brainwashed to
believe that you have to do this too
yeah um to be okay a lot of people even
in the game that see me
say that like used to be your confidence
used to be like
up there and you know i really used to
be like self-confident i used to have
self-love like not just for my
appearance but
for how i carried myself and you know
my goals and in what i was coming in
the game to get out of the game to do
and
i've even been told by people that i
know when i first started this like
even if you don't do this anymore don't
go back to that pimp
like don't go back to a certain
situation because we're like i'm
i'm afraid you're gonna die or you know
you're gonna wake up
in a hospital bed and we're gonna be
getting phone calls that either
we only have a certain amount of day to
say goodbye to you or
you're just not going to be able to say
goodbye at all
and that's when i was doing the
the fake perk 30s and
you know getting like physically abused
by the person i was staying with
and then just having to deal with my mom
and the fact that she was mad at me and
i don't
i'm not ready to face what i would call
the outside world from what's inside the
game
inside the game i feel like i know how
to get around it
i know how to at least just numb it
but now at this point with me sitting
here
and just talking about it it feels like
now
i have to deal and face like so much
more
and i don't have my mom's support like
that's the only person that i've wanted
to be
accepted and loved and forgiven by
she's not here
but i think facing it is the way it is
the only way out
because if you don't face that pain
you're going to end up using more of the
drugs and
eventually getting back into a situation
where your
your money and mind are being controlled
again
do you see that yeah then
you know my sister even says like you
can come back home but like
we need you to go to like a rehab and
you know get clean or at least get some
kind of help
from all the stuff that you've been
through since you've been in the streets
and that's the stuff that i'm not ready
for because i've already spent four
years
in treatment and those
those were the worst time moments
because i was away from my family and
away from the
being able to do what i want or hang out
with who i want
like i felt locked down and stuck
and the pills that they were giving me
from my
depression or to sleep
those just numbed my feelings like i
wouldn't really cry
they made me sleepy or if i wasn't
sleeping then i was just dealing with
the
ever therapy schedule i had going for
the wilderness program or whatever
the staff would tell me to do until i
was able to meet with my therapist and
therapy sessions would be family
sessions so
it was never it was never like
i don't know i always felt like i was
being controlled by someone
and i don't like feeling like like
feeling controlled i don't like feeling
controlled
but i also don't like i don't know how
to deal with the pain or feel
and know how to be alone
so i'm like stuck in between
and because i want to go home i want to
be okay with my family i want to be able
to have somewhere to go
for holidays or to call and
you know just be accepted by them again
and
they want me to get help they
my sister said like lina when you first
started doing this
she said you just i don't see that
bright light that you see in yourself
anymore and i said what i got mad at her
she said do you even sing anymore do you
write
do you write poetry do you you
keep track of your dreams like you used
to
and she just like reminded me of all the
things i used to do
when i was home or when i was going to
school
that kept me distracted or kept me
you know feeling like at peace with
myself and with family and
what they would call normal like i felt
normal
and it's like nothing against the girls
that
you know feel this is their life or feel
that chose them
um but i feel like something else is
like reaching and
trying to choose me or save me from and
protect me from
like i don't know
is going back to your family an option
for you right now
not right now um
my sisters and them are so mad at me
because they invited me
my mom's birthday was january 26
and i went m.i.a i even left
the situation i was in that day i
haven't been back since and
she invited me on february 14 to a
valentine's dinner
and i wasn't i didn't go
and it's not because like i like i don't
want it it's not being reached out to me
it's because i know what comes with it
if i go and the tension is there
the guilt that i left and the build the
bridges that i burnt
like i feel it like we can go and have a
family dinner and
do things and it can feel good but like
just the tension and the things that i
feel
when i'm around them knowing that i hurt
them so much
like i don't i don't like it it pushes
me away
like i start to feel disgusted with
myself
you're in a jam yeah it's a tough
situation here
yeah and the world you're living in
down on figueroa street is so dangerous
it is and as much as people make it
sound and look good it's
it's a lot of things that come with it
it's a lot of things that you have to
prep yourself for and
you know that's why a lot of people get
into drugs because they don't
they don't feel as disgusted with
themselves or feel like what they're
doing is wrong and they're going out
there and they're
good they're high that's all they that's
all they want
is a high
so what do you think you're gonna do
from here
now
i don't i don't know i might just go
no not get high probably just get
somewhere where i'm well yeah i like
smell weed yeah
but um i don't know
that's something that i need to think
about what am i gonna do now
because right now that's popping up in
my head is go get down
get some money and then
it's like damn what am i gonna do after
that because then i know i have
things to do or somewhere to lay my head
at somewhere i need to get
washed up at where you living just motel
yeah pretty much day by day
yeah which keeps you on figaro street
yep it keeps you up all night
yeah which means you need something to
help you keep up all night
yeah almost like a upper so that
i don't have to go to sleep and wake up
and not
pay my room i have the money to pay my
room
for the next day
so yeah it's a rough lifestyle
it's a rough lifestyle and it's a
like i don't know you could look at it
both good and bad
you think you're addicted to it i feel
like i
i feel like i am just for the simple
fact that like
i don't have nobody trying to get me to
cope or deal with
things that i haven't really been ready
to face or deal with
it's like the adrenaline keeps me
distracted
or the rush of getting fast money
keeps me distracted
all right selena well
thank you for sharing your story
welcome you've been through a lot with
your mom and your family and your
and your your pimps and everybody
yeah i hope you figure your way out
me too um i want to be a writer
and a life coach you know motivational
speaker i like bernie brown
she does ted talks and
something that i've want to do is
at least if i can't like share like the
depths behind my stories or like
of the trauma i face with certain dates
or certain tricks like those are books
that i want to write as
chapters to girls who either been
touched
and put in a situation they've had to
fight themselves out of
or you know girls that turn to this
and they don't have nobody not even a
pimp to
you know give them the motivation that
they feel they need when they're out
there but that just let them know that
like
i don't know i'ma figure it out though
because
that'll be what i tell them or share
with them that
will make them feel like okay i'm not
stuck in this or i don't have to be in
this anymore
and yeah
it'd be great if you turned into an
example of
showing girls how to get out yeah but
you have to do it for yourself before
you can
tell everyone else what to do yeah and
that's what
that's why yeah that's why i feel
is something i'm battling it's like what
step do i need to take to
you know walk the walk and talk the talk
i think you have what it takes you just
have to do it yeah that'll take some
courage
yeah it's that stuck feeling yeah and
where i feel
always stuck yeah if you feel stuck like
i owe
something courage is the way out
yeah in prayer and prayer yeah
lately lately i've been detoxing off
them
and that's why i feel like it's most of
my comfort is just at least praying
you know i'm talking to someone i don't
know who but i'm talking and i'm letting
it out
good for you yeah
hi john i wish you the best of luck okay
thank you for sharing
thank you really appreciate it all right
i didn't know you were going to be so
interesting my instincts must be really
good
yeah your story was incredible